i know you have to go
but do you mind me asking a marvel
question just because
i mean we know what a dead end is going
to be but yes of course you can waste
your time asking about a question
well um this is it's a two-parter i'm
just curious if you have filmed your
spider-man stuff yet
and what was your reaction looking at
that script and for dr strange
i i'm curious if you could sort of talk
about working with sam raimi because
so many of us are so excited that he is
doing an mcu movie
and i'm just if you could sort of talk
about working with him uh
spider-man yes i know uh sam amazing
and uh you know he's so collaborative
and uh god he comes with the
you know the baggage of an economy he's
just he's incredible uh
force in in in our
well especially in this genre um but
he's so humble he's so nice he's so
appreciative
you really want to serve him and boy
when he's happy you know you've done
something right and
um he's so good at getting you there and
getting it there you know uh we
we've we've it's been a very very
collaborative process this one
um you know our origin stories i guess
and obviously the beasts that were the
avengers films
to be part of were were a thrill but
you're kind of just along for the ride
you just yo
okay and and you do the best with what
you've already got given to do
and second time around there's a bit
more of like so what do you want to do
and how do we you know how do we go
about solving this so it feels very
creative uh scary so sometimes
um but it's you know we're well into it
now we've been shooting it since before
christmas and
uh you know it's a long shoot not least
because of
all the restrictions and the amazing
amount of sacrifice being made in this
bizarrio world we find ourselves in but
it's working and i feel very safe on set
this incredible
test and tracing system they've got
really is a gold standard and um
i haven't had to turn my shirts off and
shout out to people yet um so that's
good
well the thing about sam though is that
he also does
really cool camera angles anyway
you don't know he does know okay please
at least i said one more thing yes he
does and that's what i'm gonna say about
it sorry